the hotel Chester and Starkville
Mississippi is on the brink of financial
disaster and I've finally found out why
we go has been a car accident in 2008
David's car accident
send the hotel into a sharp decline Suki
is drowning in the kitchen trying to
keep the business afloat some national
wedding while her husband David isn't
taking the reins I can't see the diner
staff
so I've dashed over to the local
supermarket the least I can do to help
poor Sookie is to cook up a few sliders
before the customers walk out ridiculous
in an hour
crazy Oh buddy got some food now feel a
bit better
the burgers have brought Sookie enough
time to get through the rest of dinner
service without anyone walking out after
a long three hours everyone has finally
been fed I'm sure Sookie is as a
relieved as me that dinner service is
over
how are you Sookie fine fine yeah as a
tough one it was very tough yeah yes why
don't you guys get out of here
you go home let's hook up first thing
tomorrow morning how FAR's home away
from here this is our home now that's
wrong what do you mean this is your home
we live here you live on-site yes you
have an apartment here not right in
there that's a the handicap run that's
our that's our home now you live in the
handicapped room yes
can you show me since Dave's accident
I gave up everything we have no money so
we had no choice but to live in this
room you live in here yes there's not
even a [ __ ] window no Sookie I have
no idea things were this bad well I have
to do what you have to do I'm so sorry
you know sometimes you have
about time could you David please I
don't know what else to do we have two
children I would like for them to be not
to have to worry about their mom and dad
okay so you were running this hotel this
was your baby that's right David
yes and sadly you got involved in a
tragic car accident yes what happened I
broke both of my ankles and run back
into places we nearly lost him I mean
you know I was pretty busted up so I've
been spending most of the past five
years just recovering
why did you sell your house we couldn't
make the payment and you foreclosed yes
that's terrible I'm sorry I know that
then you come home every night now into
this bedroom
this is awful there is no way to live
I think you deserve something better I
promise I'll help you fix this place
okay yes sir
Thank You Gordon thank you we get some
rest please
sometimes our boss seven days without
stepping out of the hotel and it's uh
it's sad
I can't believe David and Sukie have
been living like this for years I've
never wanted to help two people so badly
I just hope I'm not too late